it's me now princess privacy's been at
it again
reportedly asking her bodyguards to stop
spectators at wimbledon from taking
photos of her
as she sat with 12 000 people watching a
match broadcast
to millions of people and just to
demonstrate her desire to keep a low
profile after keeping secret details of
archie's christening
and his godparents names megan is now
reportedly in talks to write a monthly
column
in vogue oh my god the hypocrisy
the arrogance the control freakery
sorry but megan isn't entitled to demand
special treatment
and people are fed up of her and harry
with their litany of imaginary
grievances
behaving like two of life's victims
rather than the luckiest people
alive fact as duchess of sussex
she can't ever be private she's not a
celebrity
she's a royal and there are duties and
responsibilities that go with
that she and harry can't snaffle
millions from the public purse to
refurbish their mansion
then scream we're private people because
they're not they're working royals who
entered into a contract with us
and if they don't want to be royals then
vacate
the mansion go live privately and pay
your own bills
[Music]
you know i'm going to be honest you and
i have clashed over this because in the
past
i think you said that we should have
been there for the christening we should
have known of the god parents
i think you even said we should have
been there for the conception
you were pushing it a bit you were
pushing it there no but actually
now i have to say i find for you this is
with a couple with a couple of caveats
um
and i'm not trying to but two of the
luckiest people alive i don't know
about harry because he has a special
place in the heart of this nation
because we watched him as a
as a lad and you would have brought a
tear to a glass eye to watch him walking
behind that guard i don't know if he's
one of those
but he now finds himself and i i
question whether it's harry i don't know
i wonder whether it's uh his wife
because the reality is and you are right
they it would appear managed to clear
people i counted the picture in the
newspaper
i stopped counting at 35 seats that have
been vacated around them
the absurdity of someone trying to take
actually it was a picture of himself
let's look at these people you've got
that picture sorry okay this is a guy
who was actually stopped from taking
photographs what he of supposedly of
megan he was actually taking a selfie he
was pointing at himself and taking a
picture
of the court in the background but let's
let's have a look at there's a security
guard telling this guy
to stop taking photographs when he
wasn't at all the guys totally remused
so we've moved to this really question
position that we have
paid i would imagine for the car to get
her and her busies
to this particular court we pay quite
rightly for her protection officers
and i'm i'm not for over-intrusion i
thought that not knowing the god parents
was really weird
i kind of got them with i don't actually
worry that much about the redoing of
their home 2.4 million
but that's a bridge too far yeah and
you're right about the god president
we don't know i couldn't tell you the
names of kate and will's godparents
right now but there were problems and we
were forgot about but i think what
people are angry at now and you like me
have sent
quite a big mood change now that this
was a bit
snitty of them it was a bit silly it
left a bad taste greg
yeah i suppose i disagree with you but
that's not surprising
um i mean it seems to me that people are
really upset
are people who work in the popular place
who who are who are i think tell me
these people you say people are really
angry okay the vips waiting to get into
that thing were angry for a start
with 40 empty seats the lady who was
told i think it's suzanne jones sally
jones the lady who was told to stop
taking p
she's just quotes a regular member of
the book it's not just
people there's a and i want them to come
back i want megan to be loved as much as
she was last may
and she will be this i really do but
they are on a cusp
really michelle see it's a tough one
because i think
where they sing in in the royal box or
something at wimbledon or whether just
they're in a private vip yeah so i just
kind of think
if you're in that public position that
is very public position
and you take the benefits and the
privilege that come with that i really
then don't think that in a public
environment where you've been watched by
millions of people
i think it's a little bit much to be
saying actually don't take my picture
step aside and all the rest of it so
it's just i
do they get some privacy in some aspects
of their life if they're on holiday
and you know kate went to wimbledon
earlier in the week she went and sat
with the crowds kate is actually a
member of women
she's a patron of the club too and she
just went and sat with the crowds no
fuss nothing
that's how you do it you don't do it
this way because she's drawn attention
to herself too
um the only thing i would say is um
i think the kind of pressure that's put
on um
megan and harry is quite unfair because
if you look at
what pressure in terms of how much
intrusion we expect from the press
no let me let me finish
but william and kate are going to ascend
the throne one day
the the positioning of william to me
harry and megan are almost
like what um uh princess margaret
and lindley were and i don't think
people were expecting this sort of thing
from princess margaret
when when she was the queen's sister and
they were young
i don't i so i'm just surprised i don't
know where you're going with well dude
they live is very private they live a
very private life already they're not
pursued
no one sells stories about them they
have they have security guards
everywhere to keep the punters away from
them and yet
they have turning up to do their charity
jobs
they're paid to be a member of the royal
let me just say this one very respected
columnist this week
said the two of them are behaving like
they're in a witness protection program
rather than the house of windsor and
that's kind of sums it up for me
they are they're living in a great life
but never underestimate
how much william and harry
dislike the media yes never
underestimate it because
i mean you know when i'm a chairman of
the f obviously i obviously work with
william and
william was brilliant with the public
actually he was really good like the
only time i ever saw him not do anything
when someone asked for his autograph and
he said
we we can't we can't give all to god
but other than that he didn't mind
everything yeah
but but uh he was willing to have his
picture
people the duchess wasn't good with two
members of the public who were trying to
take but
that is i don't mind carol and i and the
we have got broad enough shoulders you
can do what you like you can pour a tub
over my head and it has happened and i
really don't care
but ordinary people you're in a public
place these guys have gone to watch
wimbledon he's trying to take a picture
of himself and he has a scotland yard
detective telling him to stop
that's not brilliant that's not brick
let's let's look at that you might be
right let's look at kate
well on that you might be you might be
right this is a first i've got him
kate williams she's a royal history
because we want we need to talk about
the christening as well because i think
that upset a lot of people let's listen
to what kate williams has to say
harry and megan want to keep things
secret and clearly it's because they
want this child to be very protected
they chose for the child not to have a
royal title they're clearly very worried
that it will grow up in the royal
goldfish bowl but i feel very strongly
that it's going to grow up in the raw
goldfish bowl whatever they do
and so sometimes by keeping things
secret it actually makes
it more of more greater interest i think
lots of walking down the street couldn't
name prince william's god parents
princess charlotte's godparents but
because now
archers are going to be secret people
are going to start looking into that and
that is
absolutely the point and that christine
you know was a was a farce on many
levels
you know it was it was conducted in a
building that we paid for was conducted
by a bishop that we pay
the security was there we pay for that
we paid we paid for it all and yet
she made it in she and him made it into
a private i don't need to know who the
god parents are
the thing is because it's there's no
royal president for keeping it secret
and what's the big deal anyway but
why not why so why make a big fuss about
it whatever that's what
listen to what she just said you keep it
a secret and that's what happens
interesting can we get a quote from what
harry said about in terms of privacy in
2016.
so he said everyone has a right to their
privacy and a lot of the members of the
public get it but sadly in some areas
there is the incessant need to find out
every little detail about what happens
behind the scenes it is unnecessary
the private life has to be private and i
hope people respect that but so don't
take the money june
no no this is why unfortunately we have
to park company because while the
decisions regarding the quote the
the the christening were perhaps
questionable i do get it because it is
private if they want to keep it private
i know it's the archbishop country
but the ones where i'm with you is
wimbledon that's a totally i don't know
why you because
you've absolutely slammed you've aced it
six love six love regarding wimbledon
and now you've just given it a
tiebreaker i haven't given it a title
you have because the question
you know what is it such a big deal to
let the the public who you have entered
into a contract with who are paying you
to be there give them a picture
give them a smile we've got the pictures
but don't you think that matters more
for william and kate because their
children
are going to be they're both kings and
queens at some point
you and i were about to win the mixed
doubles i've just thrown the third set